Alright, so I have three and a half and I'm wondering how many times does
four-fifths go into three and a half. I know that dividing by a fraction is the
same thing as multiplying by a reciprocal, so I'm going to take three and a half
and multiply it by the reciprocal of four-fifths. The reciprocal of four-fifths
is five-fourths. Now I need to multiply these two fractions together. This three
and a half is a mixed number and doesn't help me. I'm going to change it to an
improper fraction. 2 times 3 is 6 and 6 plus 1 is 7. So I have seven-halves
times five-fourths or 35 divided by 8. 7 times 5 is 35, 2 times 4 is 8. Now I
want to change this back into a mixed number to figure out how many batches of
brownies I can make. 8 goes into 35, 4 times as 8 times 4 is 32. And I'm left
with 3 extra pieces or three-eighths. So I can make 4 and three-eighths batches
of brownies.